[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau cette ut le journal nous
sommes le 19 décembre
voici les titres le nouveau ministre de
l'intérieur bruno le roux s'est rendu ce
samedi 17 décembre à vélizy 2 avec une
sécurité renforcée durant cette période
de fêtes le ministre souhaite rassurer
avec son armée de père noël vers le
secours populaire a organisé la semaine
dernière à la dernière une braderie
ouverte aux plus défavorisés des petits
prix qui permettront à tous les enfants
de recevoir un cadeau
et puis 2016 touche à sa fin l'occasion
pour nous de vous proposer dans ce
journal
une rétrospective sur l'année de sport
qui vient de s'écouler
on débute ce journal avec la venue du
ministre de l'intérieur bruno le roux
dans les yvelines il était samedi
dernier dans au centre commercial de
vélizy 2 avec une sécurité nationale
renforcée dans les lieux publics durant
la période des fêtes
le ministre souhaite rassurer le plan
vigipirate a été renforcée dans le
centre commercial de vélizy 2 pour cette
fin d'année notamment à travers la
collaboration entre les forces de
l'ordre les agents de sécurité privés et
les acteurs de la structure c'est tout
un accompagnement sur les bons réflexes
les bons gestes en accompagnement avec
les forces de police qui sont aussi en
soutien on a des référents sûreté au
niveau des forces de police qui viennent
sensibiliser l'ensemble des commerçants
le ministre de l'intérieur bruno l'euro
est venu constater la mise en oeuvre du
plan de sécurité renforcées pour la
période des fêtes ce samedi 17 décembre
en guinée
après avoir visité le pc de sécurité le
résident de la place beauvau a tenu
aussi à échanger avec les commerçants
leur ajoutant une nouvelle mission la
protection du client
là par exemple dans cette période vous
avez du surplus de personnel des prix
n'était pas une à renforcer l'effectif
donc ça le fait partie quand il arrive
des éléments de leur dire comment on
doit se comporter s'il ya une alerte de
cetains un actif de la période que
d'avoir fait entrer cette dimension de
la sécurité au quotidien dans les plans
de formation de tous ceux qui
accueillent du public et elle me le
confirmait son rôle est d'accueillir son
rôle est d'orienter de conseiller mais
son rôle est aussi de protéger les
clients quand ils sont à l'intérieur de
son magasin
moi je ne veux aucun de nos concitoyens
ne renonce à aller faire ses courses ne
renonce à sa muse et ne renonce à venir
dans les centres commerciaux
le partenariat entre pouvoirs publics et
acteurs privés permet d'assurer le
renforcement du dispositif de sécurité
pour les fêtes de fin d'année et des
faucheurs de chaises ont de nouveau sévi
samedi dernier 10 militants fait le
siège d'une agence bnp à versailles il
dénonce d'évasion fiscale et appelle à
la transition écologique cette action
intervient suite à l' annonce du premier
procès d'un faucheur de chaises
poursuivi par la bnp paribas pour avoir
participé à une action de réquisition de
chaises dans l'une de ces agences
les petits magasins de jouets rencontre
toujours un franc succès des lieux
objets rétro et moderne se côtoient pour
le plus grand bonheur des enfants nous
nous sommes rendus dans une de ces
boutiques situées à versailles une
caverne d'ali baba pour enfants situé à
versailles difficile de se frayer un
chemin au milieu de ces joujoux par
milliers puzzles jeux de société
figurines en bois un véritable paradis
du jouet
les tout petits mais il est plein à
craquer et on est très bien conseillé
voilà donc c'est
vraiment une boîte à trésors c'est très
condensée mais il ya beaucoup de choses
il ya énormément de choix
catherine est une grande joueuse et elle
connaît tous les jeux et elle est
capable d'identifier le jeu qui
correspond à la bonne personne des cubes
alors il y en a avec des formes normal
puis on avec des formes un peu un peu
particulière pour s'amuser à faire des
empilages ce magasin est une institution
ouvert en 1972 par pierre de goncourt il
installe un petit train en vitrine qui
fonctionne en appuyant sur un bouton
cette boutique est reprise en 2008 par
catherine signol une passionnée du jouet
il faut aider le client exprimé son
besoin qu est-ce que qu'est ce qu'il
veut pour qui qui ça s'adresse une fille
et un garçon un petit un grand un adulte
voilà toutes les questions qui vont
permettre de donner le bon conseil à la
bonne personne au bon moment moi j'aime
les belles choses alors je les jouais
loi il faut qu'il soit surtout bas j'ai
très peu joué plastique c'est surtout du
bois
j'aime le bois au contact parce que
c'est agréable
ces joujoux qui ont sûrement ravi les
enfants catherine signol peut prendre du
repos pour retrouver le papa noël
l'année prochaine les familles avec très
peu de moyens ont aussi leur père noël
et celui ci est vers le secours
populaire grâce à son armée de père noël
collecte tout au long de l'année des
jouets et les revend lors de braderies
l'une d'elles s'est tenu la semaine
dernière à laterrière
un reportage de nicolas d'andré ça y est
le père noël est passé ici à la verrière
les cartons débordent de poupées
voitures et autres jouets en tout genre
tous sont étiquetés entre 1 et 10 euros
de quoi offrir aux enfants des familles
en difficulté un vrai noël ce sont des
jouets que nous collectons à la fois
auprès de particuliers des dons toute
l'année en colette et il ya eu aussi une
grande partie des jouets qui viennent de
la collègue de ski bus avant de les
mettre en vente le secours populaire tri
vérifie et si besoin reparler jouer bien
que les collectes soient effectués tout
au long de l'année
la braderie propose toutefois des jouets
dernière mode à prix cassés
vous voyez qu'il ya des jouets qui sont
venus à 5 euros alors qu'ils valent 30
ou 40 donc c'est quand même intéressant
pour tous ces gens qui sont en grande
difficulté
en une matinée la braderie a vendu pour
600 euros de jouets une somme qui
servira notamment à financer le repas du
nouvel an du secours populaire organisée
sur des péniches à paris et si vous vous
demandez encore pourquoi les père noël
sont verts voilà la réponse au début des
années 1900 le père noël était vert et
le père noël rouge il est devenu rouge
grâce à une grande société qui s'appelle
coca cola un pied de nez à une société
de consommation qui a bien inventé le
père noël rouge mais oublié de faire
profiter tous les enfants de sa
générosité
on passe maintenant aux sports les
archers de bion cours ont organisé ce
week end leur concours général une
compétition qui attire des têtes
d'affiché comme thomas faucheron ancien
marché de l'équipe de france de la
précision de la concentration c'était la
recette pour remporter le concours
annuel organisé depuis 25 ans par les
archers de guyancourt
cette année 26 ils ont été installés
dans le gymnase maurice baquet pour
programme des duels pour mettre les
compétiteurs dans les conditions d'un
championnat officiel donc les gens font
leurs tirs sélectifs et à la fin nous
mélangeons par arm les personnes pour
cuire faire un classement
ce qu'on appelle un classement scratch
et on retient les 16 meilleurs de ceux
qui ont décidé de participer aux finales
un programme qui est séduit les archers
de la région parisienne le tournoi
affiché complet avec plus de 240
participants le samedi et sont quatre
pour le dimanche je suis toujours fiable
participer parce que c'est vraiment des
gens super où il ya vraiment une bonne
ambiance et puis ce principe de faire
des compétitions et des duels c'est
vraiment très bien dans la mesure où il
ya très peu de clubs qui organisent des
finales il ya beaucoup d'archers qui
viennent rechercher cet entraînement et
du coup il ya de très bon marché dont le
niveau est tout de suite beaucoup plus
relevée que d'habitude
parmi les archers des têtes d'affiché
sébastien peineau champion du monde
individuel en quarts en 2016 est venu
supporter les sportifs thomas fauchereau
membre de l'équipe de france sur les jo
de 2012 est lui venu se tester avant la
nouvelle saison
à titre personnel j'ai fait pas mal de
changements techniques en début de
saison
des changements majeurs donc le but
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment d'essayer de
poser les changements que j'ai effectués
et de dérouler ma technique le plus
convenablement possible thomas faucheron
a remporté la finale de l'arc classique
hommes face à valentin ripaud rendez
vous l'année prochaine pour une nouvelle
édition 2016 touche à sa fin et tout au
long de la semaine nous vous proposerons
des rétrospectives place au sport et les
béninois des victoires des défaites des
records des stars l'année 2016 a été
riche en événements sportifs dans les
yvelines au mois d'avril élan courtois
d'ilham houmadi champion d'europe des
poids super-moyens depuis 2015 s'est
incliné contre le britannique callum
smith contrées dès le premier run le
sportif a été mis ko et a dû abandonner
sa ceinture à 36 ans le mois de juin lui
était traversé par un vent de fraîcheur
venus de toute l'europe les footballeurs
irlandais et russes ont établi leur camp
de base à versailles à croissy sur seine
pendant l'euro les supporters ont pu les
approcher
alors comme on disait à quand on disait
ça fait du bien de voir une autre équipe
jouer que l'équipe de france ce serait
je suis habitué plus à aller voir les
joueurs de l'équipe de france jouer donc
là de voir l'équipe d'irlande
ça fait plaisir l'équipe de france qui
était tel installé à clairefontaine a
finalement mis fin au rêve de victoire
des irlandais en 8e de finale 2 à 1 pour
les bleus à notre britannique a marqué
cette année 2016 dans les yvelines rory
mcilroy numéro trois mondial a participé
à la 100e édition de l'open de france de
golf
la superstar nord-irlandaise n'a pu
faire mieux que troisième derrière
l'italien francesco molinari et tong
chaï 10 46 ans
ça a été difficile de mettre beaucoup
leur disent les conditions n'étaient pas
excellentes pour le faire tong chaï a
joué de façon très impressionnante et je
pense que je n'avais aucune chance de
gagner un été olympique pour une dizaine
dit vinoy les athlètes en reporter au
total onze médailles 3 en or 3 en argent
et 5 en bronze aux jo de rio symbole de
ce cru exceptionnel dans la délégation
heavy noise le boxeur tony hawk a
décroché l'or dans la catégorie super
lourd
thomas baruch licencié au cercle
nautique de versailles lui décroché le
bronze avec ses coéquipiers sur le
quatre sans barreur poids léger
hier la suisse et le danemark on avait
la volonté on savait que c'était
possible qu'on avait le talent et les
capacités de le faire donc très content
d'y être
en septembre les cougars ont réussi à
remonter en première division après une
victoire arrachée sur leur terrain
contre les deux filles de saint-just ils
goûteront à nouveau aux joies de l'élite
après l'avoir quittée pendant cinq ans
ça a été une finale de folie vraiment et
nous sommes heureux qu'ils aient réussi
à avoir leurs objectifs à atteindre
leurs objectifs
moins de réussite pour l'équipe de
football américain des templiers
d'elancourt les saint quentinois font le
chemin inverse et passe de la première à
la deuxième division après avoir terminé
dernier du championnat élite
en octobre les yvelines ont connu une
nouvelle compétition d'envergure
internationale avec les championnats
d'europe de cyclisme sur piste au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le trappistes
benjamin thomas 21 ans a brillé en
remportant une médaille d'or en
poursuite par équipes le bronze sur
l'omnium et l'argent sur l'américaine
j'habite à à cinq kilomètres du
vélodrome donc la piste on la connaît
par coeur on s'entraîne moi je
m'entraîne tout le temps ici donc c'est
vrai que ça fait plaisir
ma famille qui est qui ici ma copine et
où donc c'est top
les ivy note également le pied marin
trois skippers giner du département se
sont inscrits pour participer à la 8e
édition du vendée globe
laurent blain louis burton et les
versailles et éric bellion et tanguy de
lamotte se sont élancés pour ce tour du
monde en solitaire le 6 novembre
une bonne
sans rire quoi
tout comme ça ça doit faire plusieurs
tonnes ayant termine par une épopée
historique le club des clayes-sous-bois
réussi à se hisser au 6e tour de la
coupe gambardella la coupe de france des
moins de 19 ans et que les siens petit
poucet de l'épreuve sur ce tour ont été
éliminés par caen après un match
spectaculaire perdu 4 à 3 on est fiers
représente les plus sous bois où on nous
a représentés
on se connaît dans les cent soixante
quatre meilleures équipes de france
en sachant qu'elle n'a plus de 2000
rendez vous en 2010 est pour de
nouvelles émotions sportives
c'est la fin de ce site le journal
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]